you're currently serving a 15-year
sentence for armed robbery yes ma'am
my one true love annie
doctors gave her a year
i'm gonna beg you to let me out
so i could give annie the best year of
her life
i'm so sorry
i know
reigns is right jimmy right 15 years for
picking their own kind of friends more
or less yeah why don't we make that more
or less sir
yes sir
i got a little side geek for you
well i say no
well that just makes me sad an honest
man like yourself shouldn't have to
fight so hard to make ends meet
well jimmy
a very very looking man
both are
my curry was carrying a half a million
dollars and never made it home
but if you ever want to share another
dance with your lovely woman
you better come up with my 500
you have no idea what you're getting
yourself into
you have pushed a desperate man a little
too far here temper timber
you better pray
nothing
happens oh you better pray nothing
happens to his fiancee
it takes a certain kind of woman to put
up with life like this
i'll be damned we're going to spend our
last year together running around
looking over our shoulders all the time
this ends now
you